Oh
[Music]
all right good evening welcome to Gd 50
lecture for this is Super Mario Brothers
as seen on the slides here though we're
not using the actual Super Mario
Brothers sprite sheet this is sort of
like a ripoff but I found a really
awesome sprite sheet that has all the
basic tiles that we need to get this
thing working there's a link in the
distro as to where you can find it
online I had a lot of fun playing with
it so hopefully maybe if you're curious
you can use some of the sprites in there
to go off into your own thing but Super
Mario Brothers the actual game which
this lecture and assignment are based
off of is the gay game shown here it's I
think everybody knows what it is it's
probably the most famous game of all
time but this game came out of 1985 sort
of revolutionized the gaming industry it
was the game that brought sort of the
gaming industry from a crash in the 70s
thanks to a lot of sort of poor game
making policies and companies and low QA
standards it basically took a gaming
crash of the late 70s early 80s and
brought games really back to the
forefront of people's consciousness this
and games like Legend of Zelda and a lot
of other NES titles made Nintendo
basically the Dominator of the
videogames industry in the 80s and 90s
and even today with games like breath of
the wild they're still doing their thing
but this is Super Mario Brothers it's a
2d platformer and what this basically
means is you control Mario who's a
plumber he goes around walks from like
sort of looking at him from the side he
walks left to right he can jump up and
down he's affected by gravity he can hit
blocks he can jump on enemies he can go
down pipes and there's a bunch of levels
it's it was first I'm quite a
complicated game and it spawned numerous
sort of offshoots and ripoffs and other
good quality platformers while we talk
about Super Mario Brothers today some of
the topics we'll actually be talking
about our tile maps so how we can take a
basically a series of numbers
IDs tile IDs and turn that into a game
world as you can see here the game is
sort of broken up into blocks of 16 by
16 tiles so you can see the bricks and
the question mark blocks and the pipes
are even all composed of simple tiles
they map to IDs and when you take a 2d
table or array and you just iterate over
all of it and render the appropriate
tile at the appropriate XY you get the
appearance of existing in some game
world even though it's just composed of
a bunch of tiny little blocks 2d
animation is something we'll talk about
so far we haven't really done any
animation at all in terms of at least
characters will do that with Mario he'll
have our version of Mario an alien he'll
when he's moving he'll have two frames
of animation the frames of animation
that's served like a flipbook if you've
ever used one where you can see
individual pictures and when you display
them rapidly back-to-back you get the
sort of appearance of animation we'll be
talking about that procedural level
generation we'll be making all of our
levels generate randomly so we every
time we play the game from the beginning
everything will be completely different
we don't have to hard code a finite set
of levels everything will be dynamic and
also interesting in my opinion we'll
talk about sort of the basics of
platformer of physics and how we can
apply that to our game world here
because we are just using a 2d tile our
table of tiles each with an XY that's
sort of hard-coded in the game world
space all we have to really do is take
an XY of Mario for example and then just
divide that by the tile size and then we
get basically what tile that is in our
array at that point in the world and so
it's really easy to do sort of arbitrary
collision detection on you know based on
what direction you're going and not have
to iterate over every single tile in
your world because it's just a simple
mathematical operation to get at the
exact tile given two coordinates since
the world is in a fixed space we'll have
a little snail in our game that walks
around and does a couple of random
animations and we'll go after the player
sort of like a little basic intro to AI
and then lastly we'll touch on things
like power-ups and game objects and how
we might be able to influence Mario and
pick those up and that sort of thing so
first though a demo so if anybody
willing to come up on stage to test out
my sort of implementation of Mario that
would be awesome James
I'm going to go ahead into here so
should be all ready to go so as soon as
you're ready go ahead and hit return
there and you should be up and running
so yep as a part of having random levels
so currently we have a blue green alien
the blocks have a random chance in this
case to spawn a gem and so once they do
you can pick the gem up either they have
a gem or they don't you can pick it up
and you get a hundred points as we can
see the world is sort of shifting based
on where James's avatar is so it tracks
the camera or tracks the character we
have some notion of a camera you're
getting unlucky with the block so far so
you can fall down through the spaces so
we probably want to avoid that but if
you do if you want to demonstrate doing
it up so in that case we collided with
the two blocks below it the one on the
right had the gem so go ahead and go and
just fall down so we can demonstrate so
we fall down we know we detect whether
the player has gone below the sort of
world limit and then we start them back
at the beginning of the game if you
press ENTER it should regenerate a brand
new world notice how we have sort of
random holes on the ground we have
random tiles we have random stoppers for
them all the blocks are random we have
snails now they're sort of chasing after
James he can jump on top of them there's
a lot of little moving pieces here but a
lot of them are actually pretty simple
and I'll show you great very shortly so
yeah sure that that'd be a great point
so thanks James appreciate it currently
there there is no notion of a level
ending there that's part of the piece
that actually will be spawn an object
that the player can interact with to
just sort of reach sugar a new level
basically but the whole sort of engine
behind this basic platformer is there
and it all works and so our goal is seen
here we want our goal in this lecture
sort of to demonstrate how we can get
things like a character that moves are
on the screen and a camera that tracks
their position and tiles that are
randomized and maybe there are pillars
in the ground holes in the ground all of
this again recall is at least the tiles
are stored as just numbers so you know
we all we really need to do is perform a
transformation on a series of numbers
maybe
one is equal to a tile being there zero
is equal to empty space and so you know
by just by looking at it we'll see we go
column by column we can say oh maybe
there's a chance to not spawn any tiles
along the Y column on this X of the of
the world map or on this particular Y
maybe instead of spawning the ground
level we spawn a couple above it and
down so that we get a pillar and so on
and so forth and there's just sort of
this sort of summation of these
randomizations equals a nice little
variety of game levels so the first
thing we should talk about really is
what a tile map is and what I've alluded
to so far is you can really think of a
tile map as being effectively a 2d array
or a table of numbers and it's a little
more complicated than that depending on
how complex your platformer is because
some numbers are equal to tiles that are
solid or not so you should be able to
check whether a tile is collidable
meaning that the player or whatever
entity you want to check for can
actually in a kaleidoscope layer to sort
of move freely through those but if they
run up against a wall or if gravity is
affecting them and they hit tiles below
them or above them we want to detect a
collision and then stop them based on
which direction they're moving and
depending on how complicated you get
with your platform or maybe you have
animated tiles for instance so if a
tiles animated it'll display a different
frame with animation based on what timer
you're on really the sky's the limit in
this case will be fairly simple our
tiles will mostly just be numbers with a
couple of other traits which we'll see
later on and this is just an example
here of a very simple map just a colored
background we have our character and
then we can sort of visualize all of
those tiles as being just for the sake
of theory zeros or ones yeah so tiles
zero so I actually get into a little bit
of implementation here as to how we can
get drawing some very simple tiles so if
you're looking at the distro in tiles 0
is gonna be where we start off here and
I'm just going to go ahead and run tiles
0 so we can see what that looks like so
this is just tile 0 it's a much simpler
program than what we just saw
but all we're doing here is just a color
in the background and then tiles so off
the gate anybody have any ideas as to
like what the first step would be if we
wanted to sort of implement this so put
the tiles in a loop drawn and then have
a background yes so Mexico basically if
this is main dalawa in our tiles zero
first thing we're gonna need is a tiles
table to store our we're not going to be
storing just flat numbers will be
storing little mini tables that have a
number in them an ID so we can say tile
dot ID if we have a 2d sort of table
here we have an empty table which we're
gonna populate that we have what we're
also going to need if we're gonna draw
our tiles we we're gonna need a sprite
of some kind and what I did was I just
chopped out a little segment here so
this is tiles that PNG is just literally
a one tile from the sprite sheet the
main sprite sheet that comes to the
distro and then a sort of on the right
side is just transparent so that we can
sort of offset maybe tile ID 1 is equal
to solid block and then tile ID 2 is
equal to 2 empty and so if we if we
recall generate quads we can split up a
sprite sheet into however many quads we
want to let's say this is 16 tiles tall
each tile and then the whole thing is 2
pixels wide so our two tiles wide so it
needs to be split into two separate
tiles will just generate quads and then
we'll have recall a table each of the
indexes of that table will be a quad
that maps to one of these tiles so
number one will be this tile here number
two will be the transparent bit over
here and then that's how effectively our
IDs are going to map into what gets
drawn onto the screen the ID is the
index into our quad table so going back
into tiles 0
we have here a just a map width and
height we're just gonna save draw us
generate a map 20 20 by 20 RGB we're
just gonna make it random so we're gonna
clear the screen with a random color and
then this is the sort of the quads
equals generate quads and notice that
we're passing in tile size here it's
good practice just to make your tile
size a constant so our tile size in this
entire lecture they're all going to be
16 by 16 and so since they're
symmetrical we'll just pass in tile size
tile size and then here is where we
actually end up spawning the map so
nested nested for loop why gets one a
map height X gets one to map width just
insert member we have to insert a blank
table into the base table that's gonna
act as our current row and then in that
row we're just gonna add a small @ tells
Y because Y is gonna be up here our
current row in ID and so what we're
doing here is if Y is less than five
meaning let's it were just set an
arbitrary point for the ground basically
if it's less than five tiles from the
top then just make it the sky and so sky
we've just up here on line twenty four
twenty five we just set to tile IDs as I
said before skies too it's just gonna be
on the right side of the sheet and then
ground is one it's gonna be the very
first quad generate in the sheet so if Y
is less than five that ID should be
equal to sky else it should be equal to
ground and so down here is where that
comes into play
we're gonna clear the screen with our
color or random color we're going to
iterate over the loop as James said
we're gonna get the tile at Y X tiles Y
X and then we're just going to draw the
sheet and the quads at that tiles ID and
then recall since tables are one indexed
but coordinates are zero indexed we take
the X and the y we subtract one from
them and then we just multiply them by
tile size and that has the effect of
drawing each of those tiles at their
respective point in the world and making
it seem as if we have sort of this world
this bunch of bricks with a random back
every time which isn't all that
interesting but just a little bit more
variety and so that's the very basic
gist behind I mean is essentially it's
almost the same thing as what we did in
match 3 where we just mapped the
individual tiles that were in the grid 2
indexes in the like tile sheet based on
the color and variety only this time
they are always gonna be in the exact
same place so we don't have to worry
about whether they're x and y are
different from their grid Y and grid X
we're not maintaining a reference to
those and so that's static tiles does
anybody have any questions about how we
just draw static tiles to the screen
pretty basic stuff the sort of the
namesake or the the sort of like the
whole name behind side-scrolling game is
that the tiles sort of scroll based on
what we're doing in the game it can be
an auto-scroller in which case maybe
you're like an airplane that's just like
sort of going through a level that's
scrolling automatically and you're
shooting things and you're not in really
in control of where you go or it can be
like Mario where you control an avatar
and you can walk around and jump and
stuff and the camera will always be
fixed on you and so the scrolling is
just relative to where your character's
x and y are so I'm gonna show you guys a
example of how we can get scrolling
implemented in our game and to do that
the function that we're really going to
be looking at a new function is love dot
graphics not translate X Y and so what
that does is effectively just translates
love to D's coordinate system so that
whenever we draw something it gets
automatically shifted by X Y and so that
has the effect of the camera sort of or
everything being sort of drawn skewed
based on the X Y that we pass it and so
if we maintain a reference to where the
character is we can just shift where
everything gets drawn on the screen and
that'll have the effect of it being a
camera but it's not all we're doing is
just shifting the coordinate system
based on some offset X being in this
case where the player is effectively
it does it shifts everything in the
coordinate system that you draw by the X
and the y and so that if that will
basically affect what's getting rendered
into the active window at that time so
I'm gonna go ahead and pull up tiles one
here so we can see how this works go
ahead and first run the program so for
going into tiles one in the distro
currently it looks almost identical but
I can move it if I just press the left
or right and so we can see here this is
where the 2d array of tiles gets cut off
here and then it also cuts off because
we're only generating a 20 by 20 level
it also gets cut off at the very right
side as well and these are details you
would normally hide from the user by
just clamping the X between 0 and the
sort of the right side of the map -
virtual height or virtual width sorry
and that will have the effect of
whenever you get to this point just it
won't let you go right anymore and same
thing for the left side all we're doing
right now we're not doing it based on
the character at all
we're just using a mouse or a keyboard
input so let's go ahead into tiles one
and so the important thing that we're
going to look at is as I just alluded to
we're calling the love dog graphics not
translate on some value called camera
scroll and it has to be a negative value
because if we're if we want the has to
be a negative value because if we're
moving to the right up here or to the
left if we're moving to the left camera
scroll basically is going to decrement
so it's going to get less so we can say
the camera scroll when we're going left
is going to be 0 or less if we're
starting at 0 or it's just going to
decrement if we press right camera
scroll should increase if we want the
appearance of moving to the right or
moving to the left you actually have to
translate by the opposite direction
because if everything's getting
translated if we look at this
and if we call love dot graphics not
translate positive all this is gonna get
moved to the right so it's gonna have
the appearance of us moving left and if
we translate it to the left by a
negative amount it's gonna have the
appearance of us moving right so we have
to if our scroll is positive and we want
to move to the right it has to be
actually have to translate by a negative
amount and so that's why I'm calling a
negative math dot floor camera scroll
does anybody know why we're calling math
dot floor on camera scroll instead of
just calling math dot scroll or camera
scroll negative camera scroll does
anybody remember what math top floor
does so math dot floor will return the
it'll basically truncate the number down
to the lowest number integer it
basically take off the floating point
value because we're rendering to a
virtual resolution with push and we have
fractional if we basically offset the
translation by a fractional amount
you'll get artifacting because it's
taking your window and just condensing
your image onto a virtual canvas you'll
get like weird blur and stuff like that
so whenever you draw something basically
and you and you have a fractional number
for something and you're drawing it to a
virtual canvas that's been magnified or
it's being condensed just make sure to
math.floor it so you don't get any weird
blur artifacting you can if you take
this out an experiment around or even if
in the distro you take it out of the
player's position you'll see the player
will get like weird blurry artifact D
and stuff like that so that's why that's
there in case you're curious and so yeah
all we're doing here we're just saying
if it's equal to left scroll the camera
left scroll it right or basically give
us the decrement our camera scroll and
then increment our camera scroll and
then just use the negative version of
that here you could also just assign
camera scroll equal to positive when you
move left and negative when you move
right and then you could give it the
regular camera scroll here but it's sort
of like mentally flipped in terms of
this part so I just made the decision to
decrement it here when we're pressing
left because we're going left in or
going to let a less on the X and then
more on the X when we press right does
this make sense anybody have questions
is there an equivalent is there an
equivalent function in JavaScript where
you can shift the whole coordinate
system not in base JavaScript probably I
mean I'm not too familiar with CSS there
might be a CSS function that doesn't in
a lot of engines 2d game engines yes I
would say and a lot of actual 2d game
engines will have a camera object which
sort of encapsulate this behavioral of
2d doesn't have a camera so this is sort
of why we're doing this is because it's
kind of a lower-level game framework
love to T it doesn't really give you as
many things right out the gate which
makes it great for teaching these
concepts but like a more robust solution
like unity or phaser or a lot of other
game frameworks is that they'll just
have a camera object and you just
basically give that your X and then you
just move that with the basically tell
that to track the player like camera dot
track player you know track player or
track entity player and that'll have the
same effect it's a little bit more
abstract it's a higher level than what
we're doing but it's the same exact sort
of principle underlying so any other
questions as to how this works
all right cool so that's that's all
we're effectively doing we're just
taking or just getting a camera scroll
decrementing it incrementing it and then
just every frame we're translating
everything before we draw everything you
have to do the translation before you
draw because everything that you draw
after the translation gets affected by
the new coordinate system change
so that's scrolling let's get to
actually talking about drawing a person
in Avatar more than just a excuse me a
set of tiles since that's what the game
sort of revolves around if we look at
character zero this would be our first
example here this is just going to be a
very simple example character zero you
guys probably know how this works
already all we're doing is just drawing
a sprite to the screen so just love dog
graphics draw we're getting quads from a
tile sheet so the actual I believe it's
in the slides the actual sheet is here
so we have this little guy several
frames of animation it's 16 wide 20 tall
and we just take a quad we split up into
quads first so we know that it's 16 wide
by 20 tall so we just generate quads on
this image by 16 and 20 and then in this
example all we're doing is taking the
first frame which is quads one and just
drawing that as you can see here we have
a bunch of different things we have like
a crouching stay and we'll get to more
about animations and a little bit but
here we have like him climbing up a
ladder but you can see all these
different frames well will end up
showing how you can like surf play them
back-to-back and get different
animations but for the sake of this
basic example all we're doing is just
rendering the very first frame and we
can see that make sure I'm in the right
file which I am we are getting the
character sheet here on line 43 and 44
and then we have to give them an X so
character X character
why in this case we're just setting them
above tile 7 so we do 7 minus 1 times
tile size because tiles are 1 index but
coordinates are 0 indexed and then we
just subtract the height so that he's
right above the tile instead of right at
the tile and then down here we do a love
dog graphics draw on as I said before
just character quads one just a very
basic hard coded example any questions
at all as to how this works all right so
now let's say we want him to move what
do we need what's the next step if we
just wanted him to move
yes give him an give him an x and y so
yes so he does have an x and y already
so if we look at am I in the right one
so if we go to character zero this is
character zero still we have given him
an x and a y already but there needs to
be another step what's the other step
involved so if we if we wanted to move
we need to check for keyboard input and
then we need to sort of take his X we're
just going to move him on the x-axis for
now but his we basically need to take
his X his character X variable up here I
always need to modify that we could
basically do the same thing that we did
down here in love that update on the
previously it was on the coordinate
system loved our graphics out translate
we modified the camera scroll we said
that equal to like scroll speed times
Delta time we subtracted or added it in
this case what we're doing is we have a
new constant called character move speed
and we're just doing that exact same
operation but on character ax instead of
camera scroll so the end result of that
is that we have the character here and
then we can move them left or right and
you can go off-screen now there's a
couple things wrong what's wrong what
are some of the things that are wrong
with this scene right now camera should
move with him doesn't I have animation
those are probably the two real things
that are wrong so doesn't doesn't move
our he camera does not track him which
is an important thing obviously we want
to be able to maintain a reference to
our character unless route the left edge
of the screen if we're at the left edge
of the screen this is actually okay and
that's part of the distro is we clamp
the X so that it doesn't go past the
left edge but if we're beyond the middle
you know and not to the right edge of
the screen it should be moving along
with him and vice versa and then he
needs to animate so his sprite needs to
change every sort of number of seconds
whether he's moving and it has to be
only when he's moving right like if he's
standing still I mean you can have an
idle animation like some characters will
like kind
tap their foot and do stuff like that
but let's say for the sake of this sort
of example we want him just to stand
still when he's idle and we want him to
have an actual animation when he's
moving when you take care of these two
two pieces three pieces if you count the
idle animation part so let's go into
character two and take care of the first
part which is tracking him so I'm going
to character too let's go run it first
we can see it looks like so now the
camera is basically affixed to the
player in this example we don't take
care of the left edge issue in the
distro that's fixed but we have the
basic you know side-scrolling mechanic
take a character follow him and how how
do you think that we're accomplishing
this yes
yes exactly and it can't be exactly the
character X though because if it is then
the character is going to be on the left
edge right so we need to offset our X
that we translate by we need to
basically translate by his X minus half
the screen space plus half the character
width and that'll have the effect of
translating it but always keeping that
offset half a screen width away from the
player if that makes sense and so what
we're doing is in character
I believe this caricature right
character - we're still doing the same
thing we did but actually that's the
wrong file we are modifying character X
here so you know same thing we did
before multiply the move speed by Delta
time and either add a subtracted if
we're pressing left or right but also
here we're reintroducing camera scroll
and we're setting it to like I said
character X - virtual with / - half the
screen and then positive offset of his
width / - and so that he's perfectly
right in the center because remember
characters are their coordinates are set
by their left not their center and then
we just do what we did before we
translate the scene based on camera
scroll and then we render him at
character X character Y using math dot
floor to prevent him from you know being
at a fractional point in their world
space and then being blurry and artifact
it and that's sort of it in terms of how
we can get you know tracking over
character and if you wanted to track
along the y axis you can do the exact
same thing maintain a camera scroll X
and a camera scroll Y so keep them
separated and then you would just
translate here you would just pass in so
we're doing we're passing in zero
because we don't want to track along the
y axis necessarily but all you would
need to do is then pass in your Y camera
scroll and then you could do it you know
based on character Y and whether or not
they're above the ground or past a
certain point in the sky so any
questions at all as to how the camera
tracking is sort of working here
all right so we took care of one issue
which was the sort of lack of tracking
but there was one other issue which was
he's not animated all he's doing is just
sort of walking on the you know he's
just moving sort of thing like the MC
Hammer or MC usher MC Hammer I forget
he's doing he's doing that he's not
doing anything we need to actually
animate him so that he looks like he has
some life to him and that you can also
differentiate importantly between two
separate states he can be idle
he's not moving and he can be moving so
he should be we should have some sort of
visual feedback as to what's currently
going on so anybody know how we can go
about implementing sort of an animation
for our character what are the pieces
that we'll need
yes so if he's moving right then looped
through or have a function that sort of
loops through some images that is
effectively what we will be doing we
have a class called animation which I've
introduced here and all it basically
does is Cape track of you pass it in a
table which has the frames of the sheet
that you want to animate over so we can
just pass in let's go ahead and take a
look here we could pass in and I
referenced the slide earlier but all of
these are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 however
many there are you could have you just
pass into the animation maybe you want
let's say he's on a ladder so let's say
this is 1 2 3 4 5 6 and 7 you say the
frames are going to be 6 & 7 so those
will just loop sort of left to right
starting back at the beginning when it's
finished and then you give it an
interval so say I want the animation to
happen this fast in terms of seconds so
I want to that maybe happen every 0.2
seconds and so that'll have the effect
of every point 2 seconds it'll keep
track of a timer so has have we gone
over you know 0.2 seconds start at 0 and
then add Delta time to it every time if
we have increment sort of like what our
current frame of animation is so our
current frame is this one and then you
know 0.2 seconds or elapses it's gonna
be this one and then point to second
collapses then we need to loop back to
the beginning so we'll end up using
modulus to take care of that as we can
see in the animation class basically
that's all done here so as if we have
more than one frame of animation so
recall but gets a def here so we get
frames we get an interval get a timer
that's initialized to 0 and then get a
current frame we'll say the current
frame is 1 and then as long as we have
more than one frame there's no point in
looping over you know trying to animate
any animation that only has one frame
and we can you we can of course have
animations that only have one frame idle
is only one frame of animation as we saw
here like that's only one frame we don't
need to do any sort of logic to say oh
what's the next frame because there's
only one frame but if we were to look at
character 3
we can see two frames there and then
that's just one frame
he's idle and we move left he moves in
that direction
anybody recall how we can get him cuz
obviously we saw the spritesheet just a
second ago and there was only one
direction that the sprites were facing
how we can get him to sort of look that
way even though there's no sprites for
him to look that way flip it so love dog
graphics dot draw recall you can pass in
a negative scale factor on whatever axis
you want and that'll have the result of
flipping it along that axis that's all
we're doing so this is the default frame
so just drawing it and then we have to
keep a reference to whatever direction
he's facing and if his direction is
equal to right we'll just draw that
frame and then loop or you know process
the animation if he's facing the left
draw it but also perform a negative
x-axis negative one transformation on
the x-axis and just like that we sort of
have that working so all we're doing
just keep the timer and then when the
timer goes of our interval sort of just
increment the frame and then use modulus
to loop back over it back to starting at
one and that's all done here on this
line 28 and so you can look into there a
little more if you want to get a handle
on sort of how the math works but it is
just a simple sequence of iterating over
a collection of frames based on a timer
and that has the effect just like a
flipbook as I said earlier of our
character having an animation having
some life so any questions as to how
animations are this animation class
works
so know that render is not in the
animate class so the render is I
realized I didn't show it in the actual
main here well we have two animations
here which was just the idle one so
we're just passing in one frame we're
still gonna give it an interval of one
it's not gonna really matter but just
for the sake of consistency were give an
interval of one arbitrary and we could
maybe we want to change this for
animation later so by having an interval
here we won't forget to add one later
moving animation recall ten and eleven
so it's toward the end of the sheet
we're two walking frames interval here
is 0.2 seconds we needed a current
animation to render him and then we keep
a reference to whatever direction he's
looking at so if he's looking to the
right we want to we were gonna reference
this in the loved-up graphics draw at
the bottom and that's what we're gonna
use to perform the sort of sprite
flipping along the x axis maintain a
reference to that and then down here the
part that we actually reference the
animation is on line 150 if you're
looking at character 1 and or as a
character to character
sorry character 3 if you're looking at
line 150 and character 3 we're using
current animation get current frame so
the class will actually just tell you
whatever the current frame of animation
is because it keeps a reference to what
frame it is and you know based on the
timer and like how much has elapsed
yep yeah it's it's maintaining a
reference to whatever the current like
frame is and it's in the table of frames
that it got when you gave it the
definition up at the top here lines 51
to 58 where we get where we create the
two animations basically just it
maintains a reference to which index in
this frame table we're at so if you know
0.2 seconds has elapsed we start at 1
and then we go to 2 and then we'll go
back to 1 and so it'll just basically
return frames index and frames index 1
is 10 frames index 2 is 11 and so the
function is get current frame so
character quads current animation get
current frame and then here where we
shift thee because we were performing a
in origin transformation so it's another
thing to consider when you're sort of
flipping sprites that when you flip a
sprite it actually flips along whatever
its default origin is and the default
origin of any sprite is its top-left
corner here so if you flip something
along its x-axis it'll like appear here
instead of just like flipping in place
so you actually have to set the treant
the origin to its center when you do any
sort of like in-place flipping of a
sprite so you'll notice in the code when
you're looking at it that we have plus
character width divided by 2 and plus
character height divided by 2 on its on
these two here so we shift where it gets
drawn and then we shift its origin
offsets which are here on line 160 so if
you look at loved graphics draw you'll
see it has a lot of optional arguments
and these two at the bottom are the sort
of origin offset arguments and so these
only really come into play when you do
some kind of flipping of a sprite on an
axis and you want graphical sort of
consistency not to have it flip you know
one way or the other sometimes that's
the effect you're looking for but in
this case it's not we want them to like
literally stay in the exact same place
so to flip a sprite in the exact
in place you need to set its origin to
its center not as top left does that
make sense okay and so and also here
this is the zero is the rotation here so
it's sort of required if you're going to
add the this many sort of arguments of
the function but we're testing if
direction is equal to left we want to
flip by negative one on the X else just
give it one so what one just means
default transformation so no flipping
and then we don't flip on the Y at all
so that'll always be one and so that's
sort of in a nutshell how you can get
your character to animate and also stay
in place when you animate it so any
questions as to sort of how animations
or so or the origin offsets or any of
that work okay so we talked about
animations the last thing we'll talk
about for the character is jumping so if
we recall from flappy bird how can we
get our character to jump what do we
order some of the pieces we need
yep
so yeah so keypress one thing we need so
we check for space where is gonna be the
default key Y goes up and then check for
gravity so we need not only do we need Y
but we also need Delta Y we need
velocity because gravity is this is a
transformation like on velocity not I'm
strictly on position so if we go back to
character for this is sort of a hackish
way of implementing gravity because we
haven't actually incorporated tile
collisions and I'll defer most of the
sort of implementation for that as to
the distro and I'll show I'll sort of go
over it with you guys but right now we
have the exact same thing we had before
where we have you know tile scrolling
but if I press spacebar I go up and then
he comes down and notice that he has a
in animation as well he has a different
frame so if he's jumping he's got a
little jump frame so that means we now
we have three animations we have an idle
animation we have a moving animation and
then we have a jump animation so
effectively we have three states as well
idle state moving state and jumping
state well four states actually and
there's also I noticed a slight bug here
where if you're still in the air his
frame doesn't change so it actually
probably should stay to that frame even
if he's standing still but I guess it
doesn't matter too much
we also interpreted as a feature but
he's got a couple of important a couple
of states when he's in the air
there should be two states here one is
jumping state and when his falling state
and do we know why the two being
different is an important thing
so if we think about Super Mario
Brothers and we think about the sort of
differences between jumping and falling
what are what are some of the things
that had like change based on whether
Mario was jumping or whether he's
falling
how does he interact differently with
his state with the environment I should
say so
if familiar or a fun familiar Mario when
he jumps he can actually hit blocks so
if he's below a block and he hits a
block that has some sort of behavior in
it it'll trigger whatever is in that
block whether it's a coin or whether
it's to destroy the block and if he's
falling recall he if he lands on top of
an enemy like a Goomba he'll destroy the
enemy and so we sort of need to
distinguish between these two states
because when he's jumping he's not able
to like when he's actually going up he
can't attack the enemy and likewise when
he's falling down he can't destroy the
block so there's even though he's
jumping up in the air you know and the
sort of gravity is applying a
transformation and it sort of all looks
like one state there's actually two
important states two important changes
in his state that are relevant and
that's something that we'll need to pay
attention to and it's in the distro he
has a falling state and a jumping state
even though they share the same
animation they have different behavior
so let's go ahead and look at the
character for distro here so what I've
done here is I've added a delta Y for
the character so just like in flappy
bird when we press space and we made our
Delta Y go up to like negative 50 so
instantly like shot up pretty high
because I was getting applied every
frame same thing here
once we get once we press space we're
gonna change Delta Y to negative 50 if
we go down to where is it at so
right here so if the key is equal to
space I have it in the love key pressed
function since we're doing all this in
matin about Lua just for illustration
things are a little just sort of simple
if ki is equal to space and his Delta Y
is equal to zero what would happen if we
didn't check to see if Delta Y was equal
to zero you know we'd be able to jump
infinitely so we have to do a check for
that we said his dy to jump velocity
jump velocity is a constant up top
online somewhere up here 29 which is
this negative 200 and then gravity is
equal to 7 and so what we do is we set
it to negative 200 his Delta Y as soon
as he jumps and then every frame down an
update we set we basically increment his
Delta Y by gravity and then we increment
his Y by Delta Y times Delta Delta Y
times Delta time I still have the effect
of it when he's in the air and he's got
a negative velocity it'll actually start
becoming positive and positive until it
is positive and then he falls back to
the ground and then the hack that I was
referring to earlier since we don't have
collision detection implemented in this
example yet is we're just basically
checking to see whether he's gone below
the maps floor while we set the maps
floor and if he has then set his
position first of all to be above that
tile here on line 133 and then say this
Delta y equal to zero and that'll allow
us then to hit space again because Delta
Y will be equal to zero
there is always gravity something I
realized like shortly before lecture but
all you would really have to do is I
think if character dy yeah there's the
you could easily take that out of there
just an if statement around it it is I
mean it's not it's not expensive because
all you're doing is incrementing it
variable by certain amount but it's
something because if anything if you're
introducing an if condition every frame
which is probably the same if not
actually more I think a branch is more
CPU than just an assignment I'm not
entirely sure about that
but yeah yeah in this case it doesn't
really have any side effects but it's
good thing to to notice but now notice
that we can just sort of walk along the
floor here because there's no policeman
protection we'll talk about how we
implement a collision detection soon so
one thing that will start talking on and
we'll take a break fairly soon is
procedural level generation so I am a
big fan of procedural level generation
and platformer levels are actually
fairly easy at least in a simple sense
to procedurally generate and so like
with match three we all we basically did
was just loop through our grid and just
say oh you know get a random color and a
random variety and then you know with
the assignment it was a little bit more
complicated where you actually had to
check to see whether you were on level
one and then if you weren't then your
variety should be you know maybe a
certain amount depending on how far
along you progressed in the game with a
procedural level with a platformer level
sorry we sort of have to think about how
we can take that basically grid of IDs
of tile IDs and sort of think about it
mathematically how can we how can we
sort of get the results of a level but
make it different every time like
introduce some variation right and so
the solution that I found that makes the
most sense is going sort of column by
column so here if we just have a you
know a bunch of this is just a very
simple perfect screenshot to illustrate
it very simple we have generate
the level but you know recall if we just
think about these tile IDs of these
tiles here it's empty spaces being like
a zero and these being like a one go
sort of almost like binary in this case
we can just we could just fill the
entire thing with zero first just you
know assume empty space and then we
could just grow by our column by column
just go down and just have a chance
every column okay do I want to generate
a ground here if I do start at like the
ground level and then just generate
earth tiles all the way down and then go
to the next x position do the same thing
do the same thing and then every maybe
every column of the world that you're
generating you also have a chance to
generate a pillar like this so if like
generate pillar is true then I want to
spawn instead of starting the ground
here I want to start it here and then
maybe you have a flag that says okay you
know not only don't want to generate
pillars I also want to generate just
chasms just empty space obstacles for
the player right because if he falls
down it goes below the world space it
should be game over so in that case you
just say if like generate chasm make no
math dot random ten or whatever it is
then just like go to the next X like
don't even do anything and then I'll
have the result of generating a chasm
and so a little like little piece by
piece while doing small things like that
has the net effect of you know
generating a lot of sort of visually
interesting dynamic and random levels
you never know what to expect and this
is a very like very basic example you
could go infinitely far with it however
many ideas you have in terms of sort of
how to create obstacles and interesting
levels and senior for the player like
you could absolutely implement that
yeah so if it's a platform so it depends
on how you want to implement platforms
if it was a less if you wanted to
implement and this is actually I did a
seminar on Super Mario Brothers and we
did platforms as like tiles in this case
we'll have blocks that are actually what
are what we've denoted as game objects
which are a little bit different than
tiles because they can have arbitrary
sizes and they no necessarily have to be
affixed to the world grid but if you
were to treat these tiles as if you were
to treat a platform that was like let's
say two tiles wide by as tiles all you
would do is just basically have a flag
like up here that's like generate
platform equals true or whatever turn it
off after however many iterations you
also need the size of it you'll need a
flag that's like platform width equals
however many and so you'll just keep a
counter it's like a current platform
tile equals one two three and if that's
equal to width then you don't generate
it anymore and that has the effect of
potentially colliding with pillars if
you don't account for that so you can
also in your logic say if I'm generating
a platform right now like don't generate
a pillar but you could generate a chasm
because the chasm doesn't interfere with
your platform and then you can also just
if you don't have things as if you don't
have platforms as tiles if they're
different objects then you can just you
don't have to do it during the actual
world generation phase you can just test
you can just create a game object that's
a platform at a certain you know
depending on how complicated your
algorithm is maybe make sure that it's
not next to a pillar when you generate
it and you could just do that by getting
like the tile here and then looking at
the next four tiles something like that
we don't do platforms in this example
but it's something that you could pretty
easily do with tiles and fairly slightly
more difficult but it's also still
fairly easy to do with game objects
through which we'll a twitcher which is
included in the distro and we'll touch
on in a little bit
let's see we're at level oh and another
a couple things that I wanted to show
before we actually start getting into
the code for how to generate levels is
this is the sprite sheet for this whole
project which is a really cool
spreadsheet that I found online it's in
the spirit of platformers like Mario and
it's got a nice little mock-up here on
the right so I encourage you to take a
look at that and just maybe get some
inspiration and see all the different
cool stuff tinker around with it if you
want to but as you can see here there's
a couple of pretty prominent things we
have a ton of tiles these are all tiles
here different tiles and variations and
then we have a ton of these toppers here
and so what really I think helps this
whole sort of demonstration of
generating these levels is the fact that
we have so much visual content to work
with and so here again are the tiles
here are the toppers and then when you
sort of take the two together and then
you you know also have these random
backgrounds you like these are toppers
here like the little top of the tiles
here it's incredibly easy to just have a
sheer abundance of visual variety and
interesting things in your game levels
without even and this other algorithms
here are very simple all we're doing is
just you know checking this generate
pillars and columns I know I thought it
was I thought it was really cool and
sort of helps illustrate the sort of
importance and power of the this whole
procedural approach to creating the
levels for this and there's actually not
that many games that take advantage I
think of procedural level generation in
the platformer genre plenty of games
like Minecraft and Terraria I mean
terraria is a great platformer that is
an example of that but I don't think
I've seen a like a really good Super
Mario Brothers game that does something
like that but let's see what time is it
63 why don't we take a let's take a five
minute and then as soon as we get back
from that we'll start going into how we
actually can implement this sort of
procedural level generation in more
detail alright welcome back this is
lecture four and before we took a break
we were talking about procedural level
generation in the context of platformer
levels so recall here are just a few
examples
balls that I took pretty quickly of sort
of my code and you can see they have
different backgrounds different tiles
differently you know sometimes we have
chasm sometimes we have pillars we'll be
talking about a few ways to do the tile
version of sort of that because there's
just two levels here in the distro
you'll see there are also things like
bushes for example we can see in the top
middle there the purple cat wall I guess
those a little like purple cacti and
then like the one right below that there
is a pillar with a yellow sort of fern
on it
those are separate objects from the
tiles game objects but the actual tiles
themselves will sort of dig in here a
little bit as to how to get those
generated so the first thing we want to
look at level zero is just some flat
levels so just basically what we've
already done so I'm going to go ahead
and go into oops not love zero levels
level level zero and then if we see here
we have a simple flat level just like we
did before
now the tiles are different and if I
press R they're randomly generating
every time so you can sort of get a
sense of just how visually diverse this
sort of generation looks I mean we're
not even though I think that was might
have been a bug earlier I'm not sure I
haven't seen that yet but we can see
here I'm pressing R all I'm doing is
taking the basically the array of tiles
that we have and I'm assigning it a tile
set and a topper set in the case of sort
of this the scope of this generation so
recall that the topper is just the top
layer sprite and the tile set is just
the sort of the tiles underneath anybody
know sort of like wanted just suggests
how I'm sort of rendering the topper
versus of the tiles and what's going on
there
yes I mean yeah and then a nutshell I'm
just pulling the stoppers from a
different part of the sheet an idea how
I'm storing the information like what's
being stored here to get it to render
like this yes so you could store the
position of the topper and know that
everything else is below that that would
that would work for a flat level it
would be a little bit I don't think that
would be reliable for a level that has
pillars on it because the pillars are a
higher elevation than the ground and
then there's also chasms and stuff like
that the so what's going on here
actually is restoring a basically a flag
in a tile that says whether or not it
has a topper on it and if it has a
topper then we render not only the tile
but as soon as we render the tile we
also render the topper and I won't go
too deep into the code here but what
we're doing to get all these different
tile sets and topper sets to is we have
to take all of these basically tile sets
these collections of tiles and sort of
divide them up right we have to know
that we're like if we want to render the
entire level in tile set 1 then we
should you know have basically take this
into its own sheet its own table this
into its own table this into its own
table
going left to right actually and we have
basically a sort of like a 4 nest a
4-way nested loop so we go you know
every set on the X by every set on the Y
and then within each of those we want to
look for every tile along the X and
every tile along the Y therein and split
up the tile sets so that we can index
into the individual quads so in the
actual code I won't go too deeply into
it here but I'll show you where it is if
you're curious to look into how we do
that it's in Mario in source util Allah
which is recall where we before stored
our generate quads function which does a
simple split on a tile sheet along its
you know just along x and y based on
whatever width and height you
we have in here also a generate tilesets
function which takes in the quads from a
generate quads table so we first
generate quads on all of this or all of
this so we have every single frame of
this divided by 16 which is I don't know
how many that is 6 by 5 times 1 2 3 4 5
10 by 5 10 by 4 that that many quads so
like thousands of quads
I think if not hundreds it decided
pretty sure it's thousands of quads and
then we take that and then divide it
into using the number of sets on along
the x-axis sets on the y-axis and then
the size of each tile set on line the X
and size along the Y we do I four ways
basically divide it using a 4-way nested
loop here basically just divide it up
and then do the instead of doing a
generate quads along the entire entirety
of the picture we just do it along a
basically do a 2d slice of that quad
table we get back from the first
generate quads call so I encourage you
to sort of look in here and experiment
with that you don't need to necessarily
know how it works for the assignment but
that's how we can basically take a giant
sheet like this and easily just sort of
integrate it into our code we can just
swap in and out whatever active tile
sheet we want to work with assuming that
everything is cleanly laid out like this
which is on part of you or your artist
you want to make sure that everything is
conducive to you know programmatic sort
of organization had things been you know
scattered around in a very awkward way
maybe things were like zigzagged or like
there were weird spaces or something
like that we wouldn't be able to do
something as clean as what we did here
in Utah Lua
with just you know 63 - like 20 lines of
code but you know getting each
individual tile set so that's an
important consideration if you're
looking at creating you know assets for
your project and you want to do some
programmatic hot swapping of your tile
sets let's make sure we're going to
write we're not in the right example
here so we're going to go into level 0
into Maine and we keep track of we have
constants now for all of our tile sets
and what the height is and how many they
are wide by tall and we effectively do
yeah we do here we do we get our regular
quads from our tiles and Stoppers so
these are just literally every single
tile within that big tile sheet put in
one table and then we just divide it up
into tile sets and topper sets here with
generate tile sets function and then we
get a random tile set and a random
topper set here if Matt thought random
number of tile sets number of topper
sets and then at the very bottom also we
have a generate level function 2:23
which is going to be built upon in the
next two examples level zero just flat
levels so it's actually exactly what we
saw before which was just if you know ID
is less than if y is less than seven ID
should be equal to sky or ground and
then this this part is actually what I
was alluding to before with the topper
because recall we need to store a flag
in a tile to render a topper or not and
it should be whatever the top tile is in
the in the level on the ground in this
very simple sort of flat thing we can
always assume it'll be the same Y level
in this case if it's equal to 7 then
topper should be true otherwise false so
every tile along y 7 is gonna have
topper equals true and this comes into
play up here if we do love dog graphics
to draw tile sheet we have not only just
tiled ID as we did before but we have
tile sets indexed into tile set now so
remember tile set got a random value
between 1 and however many tile sets we
had that we sort of spliced out of our
massive
tile sheet now we just index into that
and then we index into tile that ID and
tiled ID will then be whatever you know
our ID is but relative to that sheet not
the whole entire sprite at once
and the same thing for topper we have a
topper set we index into topper sets
here at the topper set that we got and
then that's where we'll have the
collection of tiles that form that
particular set and so that you are
completely separate that can be a one
random color tile with one random topper
but it's consistent its global we have
one topper set one tile set that are
active at any one time and if we press R
which I did up here then we just reset
them to random online 139 140 tile set
gets a new random number topper seconds
and a random number has the effect of we
can just walk around and this generate
random sense so pretty simple and recall
again topper is on because the tile that
we're standing on is why seven topper
equals true so in that case the that
particular top layer those gonna have a
topper and it gives us a nice little bit
of visual variety because it actually
makes quite a bit of a difference having
a topper versus no topper and you could
also just not have a topper and consider
that an permutation of the toppers x
tiles like procedural algorithm but
that's flat levels does anybody have any
question is there like sort of how this
works or what would do anything that
we're doing here okay so things are a
little flat a little boring the next
step will be actually introducing one of
the things that we can see here in our
little collection of sample levels like
this pillar right here in the very
middle there's anybody recall how we go
about spawning a pillar as opposed to
just flatland
yep so for that column just put more
tiles down instead of just the ground
level it's exactly what we're gonna do
so I'm gonna go ahead and open up level
one in main and I'll run the example
here as well just so you can see what it
looks like whoops
so here we have a few quite a few and
notice we haven't implemented collision
so we're still walking through them but
we have you know there's random the
random amount is up to taste really
right here it's pretty common so it
might be worth lowering the amount a
little bit if you wanted to you could
also maybe have a flag that says spawn
pillar and maybe you want a pillar width
you could have you know anywhere between
one and three tiles and if its width is
you know greater than one then just you
know like loop over a few times and just
like draw that same height a few times
as opposed to just one time and then set
the flag back to false a lot of things
you could do with it and also they're a
little tall here for the main destroy I
ended up making them a little shorter
but we'll see how we do this in the code
here it's gonna mostly be down in our
generate level function so what we're
doing here go ahead and hide that is we
have the we have this basically this
code here line 227 to 236 so we're all
we're doing here is just filling our
entire thing with just the sky we're
just sitting the entire thing to empty
and now we have a fully populated 2d
array all we can do all we need to do in
order to change a tile we don't have to
worry about insertions or like over like
you know adding too many tiles to our
array all we can do now just directly
change whatever tile exists there so all
we need to do is starting on line 239
we're gonna start doing the column by
column iteration over our entire level
and deciding whether we should generate
pillars or not and we're always gonna
generate ground so here's a very here's
the flag spawn pillar and if it's equal
to one this is going to basically be
assigned to spawn pillar so map that
random 5 is equal to 1 we have a 1 in
a chance of spawning a pillar if we do
spawn a pillar then just pillar gets
equal to 4 from 4 to 6 so from tile y4y
gets 4 to 6 effectively tiles at pillar
X ID ground and then here's where we
said the top I recall because now
pillars can be the top most tile
basically on the surface but they're
above the ground level so we just
basically say when we're generating a
pillar
if topper air if pillar is equal to 4
which is the very first tile that we
start at then set topper equal to true
here otherwise set to false so that's
how we can get pillars to also have
toppers and then always Jenner in this
case we're not generating any chasms yet
so all we're gonna do once we've
generated pillars once we've generated a
pillar on that particular column will
just say ground gets 7 until the map
height so till doors the very bottom of
the screen and then we'll just set it to
ground and then topper in this case
we're gonna make sure that we're not
spawning a pillar because if we if we
don't check this then it'll also spawn a
topper like where the pillar meets the
ground and it'll look a little bit silly
and then we also want to check that
ground is equal to 7 and so altogether
that has the effect of sort of this
behavior and so if we didn't check for
that not spawn pillar we'd have like a
topper right below our feet here too
which is looks graphically strange but
that's how and and also you can see like
emergently we're getting like double
sided or double width pillars and that's
just kind of a natural byproduct of a
lot of these randomizations a lot of
these sort of procedural algorithms
they'll generate outcomes that you might
not necessarily have anticipated which
is kind of a cool thing like you didn't
necessarily program it to have pillars
that were two tiles wide but just the
nature of randomization that's just sort
of what you get and that's another
exciting thing about procedural level
generation is like it can surprise even
the person that wrote the algorithm like
it's just it's really cool and it saves
you work having to create levels so that
was pillared levels Kazim's levels whoo
can tell me how we can do Kazon levels
yep
you skip you skip a column so at the
very beginning all we can just basically
say is do I want to generate a chasm
here if I do just skip go to the next
iteration of the loop and so we'll take
a look at that even as simple as it is
because Lua doesn't have the notion of
continue this will be a refresher
because I believe this was in one of the
assignments
it has a go-to statement so basically
same code as before starting at you know
calling my column x equals 1 until map
width if we have a one in seven chance
just arbitrary and this should ideally
if you're engineering an entire you know
large game or application this would be
called like spawn chasm chance probably
and you set that to seven somewhere for
just setting it to seven here just a
static magic number but magic numbers
are generally bad go to continue and so
continue is here at the very bottom of
the sort of the loop here which is this
for x equals one map width so it'll have
the effect of skipping straight to x
equals two if this is that one for
example a lot of languages just simply
have continued lua does not have
continue so this is a community
established sort of tradition for
implementing continue like behavior in
lua you create a label via double colon
with a name and then a double colon and
then you just go to it and so that's
that's as simple as it is for generating
chasms and so if we go back to if we go
to level two and run that we get chasms
and so now we've got sort of like a
little bit of interesting visual variety
it's not spawning a ton of chasms in
this example it spawned one so far
there's another one and then sometimes
you know just emergently you can get to
own let's see there we go we get some
interesting obstacles as a result like
almost looks as if someone intentionally
did that
most I would probably like I said shrink
the pillar size a little bit it's a
little tall but that's that that's basic
procedural like in the context of
platformers like that's how like that's
the mental model for how we can start
thinking about generating you know
obstacles and there's a lot of different
directions you could go let's say you
maybe wanted to like generate pyramids
of I mean there's a common thing in like
Mario like there'll be the steps and
excuse 50 has a piece set for it like
the same implementation would basically
happen here I mean it would be a little
bit different because you're doing it on
a column by column basis but you would
effectively just maintain a reference to
something like step height and then you
would say like generate stairs is true
here and then you would just set step
height to one so then you add a tile
here you would go it from ground level
up until step height generate a tile go
the next one and then increment step
height to two and then do from you know
ground until step height tiles go up so
one and then two and then three until
you've gone two stairs width in which
case you stop generating stairs like
that's you know this sort of principle
behind how you could do something like a
little more complicated or a pyramid
same exact thing pyramid width and then
you just go until pyramid width equals
or we're at pyramid with divided by 2
you know make you go up and if it's if
we're higher than that just make it go
down and then you have the effect of a
so the pyramid approach yeah
in this case it's all in main.lua
but in the distro it's gonna be in level
maker da lua so we've broken out all of
this functionality into just sort of how
we did what was it break out we had a
the same sort of thing level maker and
it just has level maker generate and
then you give it a width and a height
and then it'll generate an entire level
for you the question is does it generate
continuously or as or all at once it
just generates all at once so you could
implement a if you wanted to do like an
infinite runner you could do a you could
the way you would do that is you would
break up your level into chunks and with
infinite runner is usually you can only
move in one direction so as you go right
your levels that you've generated before
they get discarded so you avoid like
memory overconsumption what you would do
is you would just generate a chunk like
maybe a 100 by 20 level and then you
would like you know going through that
through that and then when you get to
like level end - maybe like 5 tiles or
10 tiles you would generate another one
append it like put it to the right and
then you would just like you know go
from the left to the right and you
probably would need some sort of fancy
semi fancy code to sort of like splice
them together once you've generated them
alternatively you could just always pad
your own I probably wouldn't to pad I
would say yeah I probably just spliced
the splice um end to end and then get
rid of x equals 1 to 100 or however many
on the left once it's gone past the left
edge of the screen but in this case to
summarize yeah just it's all static but
you could very easily not easily but you
could very well make it an infinite
runner yeah
the question is are we rendering the
entire level but we just can't see it
all the answer is yes currently in this
implementation we're just rendering the
entire level so tile by tile is getting
drawn to the screen for small examples
like this it's not a concern but for a
large level like if we did like a
terraria level for example two areas
like thousands and thousands of tiles
wide by like probably a thousand or more
tiles tall you want to render only a
chunk only what you can visibly see and
for that you could use your camera
offset and then just like render one
tile from one tile to the left and above
that to one tile below the bottom edge
of the camera and to the right of it
just render that subset of tiles so you
just need a loop a for loop to iterate
over a small section
question was you just have a
multi-dimensional array of tiles for
your level and you surrender it as you
go the answer is yes you would have your
overall tiles your big 2d array of 100
by 20 or however many thousands of tiles
and then based on wherever your camera's
rendering you just draw a it's just a
for loop within that just have a nested
amount so from like maybe your player is
it like X play like 30 plus 6 tiles
see we just render from like 30 tiles to
like maybe 45 tiles on X and maybe 10 to
20 on the Y just that chunk and it's
just relative to where your camera is
you're always rendering like just a
small little it's basically it is
effectively a camera at that point
you're just rendering a chunk of the
tiles to the screen in this code no and
the levels here are it's sufficiently
complicated to introduce and it's I mean
it's not too complicated to introduce
it's pretty easy but the the consumption
the sort of like the processing here is
very light because the levels are fairly
small and even if we did have really
large levels it's substantially it's
sufficiently small it's gonna have to
worry about it but if we did get to a
point where your levels were a thousand
tiles or more and then maybe those tiles
have additional like you have you just
want to squeeze all the performance
possible out of your application you
could look into just rendering a subset
it's fair it's fairly simple to
introduce but just not something that we
included in this assignment so any other
questions as to how this sort of thing
works
okay so so far we've talked about
procedure level generation we've talked
about sort of animation and rendering
and all that stuff we haven't really
talked about how to do tile collision
and we won't go into a terrible amount
of detail because the code is a little
lengthy it'll be part of your assignment
to sort of read over it and understand
it but it's in the tile map class that
we have basically the the point the
whole gist is that because we're on a 2d
tile array basically that's fixed it'll
always be at zero zero at least in the
model that we've currently implemented
we can just convert coordinates to tiles
and then just check to see whether or
not the tiles at whatever you know
whatever that is are solid or not so
like we can check our character let's
say we wanted to look at the the sort of
left like the top of our character in
this case so if we have our character
here and let's say he's for the sake of
illustration I put in between two tiles
above him just to show why we need to do
this the way that we are doing it but
you take the point here this is very top
left so player X and then player dot Y
which is effectively their version of 0
0 and then player X plus player dot
width - we do a minus 1 just to for a
lot of actually the sort of collision so
that he can like walk between blocks and
stuff like that because if you don't if
you don't basically give him a slightly
less than the amount because he's 16
pixels wide and the tiles are 16 pixels
wide if he's between like two blocks he
wanted to fall down he just won't fall
down because it's still detecting a
collision because it's even though it's
because if he's on the hole here let's
say this is the hole and is this is a
the tiles here the X plus the width
it'll it'll trigger a collision on this
tile and this tile still so basically
you need to minimize his collision box
by one pixel to fit through 16 pixel
gaps essentially is what it boils down
to
but the the gist behind collision in
this case this would only apply when
he's jumping because this is the only
time at which he can he can really
collide with tiles that are above him
you would test for whatever block falls
on this pixel and whatever block falls
on this pixel and if either of them are
solid you trigger collision and if not
then there's no collision at all so if
he's like right here for example like
right directly beneath the tile it's
only gonna check one tile this point and
this point are both going to fall on
this tile but the reason that we want to
check for both points here and here is
in the event that he is beneath like two
separate tiles because now this point is
gonna check this tile and this one's
gonna check this tile we can't just
check this tile because if we only check
this tile and there was no tile here but
there was a tile here him jumping would
still not trigger a collision because it
wouldn't it would think that it was only
looking here and not here so we need to
check for every collision on every side
we do of him effectively we need to
check his top we need to check both
corners of that of that edge effectively
so when he's jumping we check we turned
this point this XY into a tile by just
dividing it by tile size so we can say
player dot X divide it by tile size plus
one that's going to equal whatever tile
this is on the X and then same thing for
the Y we just divide the Y by tile size
and then we add one to it and that'll
that'll allow us to get the exact tile
if we use those XY that we get from that
math from that uh operation we get the
exact tile at that Y X index in our
tiles 2d array effectively so we do that
for jump we check both corners of his
top of the top of his head
we do the same thing for the bottom only
at that time we're checking X and then Y
plus height and an X plus width y plus
height and then if we're doing the left
edge what are we checking
we are so there'll be X 0 Y and then X 0
y plus height and if it's the right edge
same thing we check X plus width Y and
then we check X plus width
y + height and so that's the gist behind
collision detection in the distro here
and you can see it in Mario if we go to
his I forgot a tile map point to tile
this is effectively where it happens so
notice that we are doing on line 32
basically returning self dot this this
bit of code here 28 to 30 is a check
because we can jump over the map edge we
won't be able to check at tile y divided
by X plus 1 X divided by tile size plus
1 because those will be nil those one
exists because he'll literally be
outside the map boundaries same thing if
he like goes below it or he let goes
beyond the left or right edge so that's
all this code is here it just makes sure
that if we do go beyond the map
boundaries we return nil so that way we
can check nil rather than getting a tile
index error and then on line 32 is the
operation that I just mentioned which
was we take the Y so this this x + y
that we pass in are gonna be the
player's actual XY when we pass those in
we're just gonna get the tile at self
dot tiles and then effectively Y divided
by tile size taken down to an integer
and then add one because recall
tables are 1 indexed but pixels the
coordinates are 0 indexed so this will
result in a 0 indexed outcome so we want
to add one to it
same thing for here math dot floor X /
tile size plus one so effectively points
to tiles and then we can we'll just get
a tile from that and the tile we can
just check hey is that tile solid or not
if it is trigger collision so that's the
gist behind
being able to do it in a platformer
where everything is fixed that's sort of
like a shortcut we can take because now
like what's the what's the what's the
nice thing about this what what jumps
out as being like a super nice thing
about this algorithm imagining that we
have let's say we have 10,000 tiles in
our game world
so if you look and see all we're doing
is we're we're just doing a simple
mathematical operation on what X what
his x and y is right what's the what's
the alternative to this like if we were
doing this via a a b b for example we'd
have to iterate over every single tile
right yep so the gist is he's got an x
and a y the excellent y you're gonna be
in world coordinate so his x could be
like 67 and his y could be like 38 or
something like that they don't map
evenly two tiles but if we divide those
by whatever the tile sizes in our world
16 that's gonna be the exact tile that i
mean if we also have to add one to it
because the tables in lua are 1 indexed
but we can index ourself tiles at the XY
that we get from that then dividing it
by 16 and that'll be the exact tile that
is colliding with and so we don't have
to we don't have to iterate over we
don't have to basically have a
collection of tiles that we iterate over
and check whether they collide with the
player using a ABB collision detection
like we've done before because we're
calling break out we had the bricks
right they all had their own XY but they
weren't on a grid they weren't fixed so
we had to actually like take them and do
an a a B we had to iterate over them and
perform a a b b on them because there's
no really deterministic way to just
index at them really quickly it's the
same thing with like arrays versus
linked lists like because arrays you can
calculate how far some value is given an
index you have instant access to it it's
a you know order of one operation or as
opposed to a linked list if you want to
try and you know get to particular value
you have to iterate through the entire
thing until you find it
you look for the you're looking you're
getting the exact tile at whatever your
ex divided by 16 or whatever your tile
sizes and your Y divided by 16 is and
you're doing it recall for two different
points depending on what you're looking
for if you're looking for the tiles that
are above your character you're gonna be
doing it for this point so whatever this
value is his base XY whatever that is
divided by 16 and then whatever that is
divided by 16 and then that'll get you
whatever tiles are directly above them
right it'll intersect with whatever tile
intersects with this point and whatever
tile intersects with this point same
thing with here and here if we're
looking on the left here here if we're
looking on the bottom in here and here
if we're looking on the right side and
this is done we check for collision
after he's already moved so that these
points will have and it will be
intersected with potential blocks and
that's how we can check whether it's a
collision or not we do this when he's
when he moves and is in some sort of
movement state is it
yep yep we're just we're turning it from
a like iterative like iterating over
every single tile to an instant
operation because we can just
mathematically getting the exact tiles
that he's at without having to go worry
about where he is in the map it's just
instant it's in access and this only
works because we can we know the tiles
are always fixed in the exact same
locations they're always starting at
zero zero they're always gonna be tile
size things get a little more more
complicated when we introduce game
objects which have their own you know
independent XY and for those you do have
to iterate over you have basically a
collection of game objects or a
collection of entities like let's say we
have snails in the game world the snails
aren't going to be at you know some
fixed location every time they can move
continuously so for those we have to
actually keep them all in a container
and then loop through them and say has
my player interactive or collided with
any of these if he has then trigger a
collision with that snail kill it or you
know kill the player if it's if he's
like in a walking state or a jump state
and if he's in a falling state then they
should die because he's colliding with
them from the top right and you can you
narrow down what collision you check for
as you can see at the bottom here tile
collision when you're looking above your
character you're only testing that when
you're in the jumping state because it's
the only time you need to so that's the
only point at which you'll collide with
tiles that are above you when you're in
the falling state is when you'll check
for tiles below you and then you can
interact with tiles to your side when
you're in either the jumping falling or
moving state so you should check for
left and right tiles and all three of
those states yeah
and in case what in case you get chasm
yes in in walking did I Oh
you're correct this should actually be
tested only when in the player falling
state and player walking state yes so he
said the question was shouldn't you be
testing for tiles beneath you when
you're walking and yes not falling not
just falling but walking as well this
one only jumping this one falling and
walking in this one for jumping falling
and moving does that make sense the how
like we can take the XY and sort of turn
that into a tile by just dividing it by
sixteen and do note the plus one as well
because our tiles in our self dot tiles
are one indexed and so when we divide
the XY by tile size we're gonna get a
zero indexed coordinate like if we're at
tile it give our X is at like 14 right
and we are within the first tile but if
we divide that by 16 we're gonna get
zero so we need to add one to that so
that we get the first tile in the array
still which will be whatever that tile
is so that's sort of like how the
collision works it's all implemented in
tile map here so and then every player's
basically every state that the players
in which is in States entity and then
player falling idle jump and walking
these are all states that perform this
check they check to see they basically
do all the logic that's here at the
bottom which is testing in the player
jumping state falling state and moving
state for left to right collision and
then in the falling state we check for
collision below us and then jumping
state we check for collision above us
that's all done state within the state's
themselves but the actual transformation
from pixels to tiles that takes place
that's just a function that we call from
tile map it's just a utility function so
yeah it's called point to tile so if
you're in a tile map online 27.2 tile XY
and the the first little bit here is
just a bit that lets you
basically go outside the map bounds
without getting a tile index error so if
it's you know just outside the town
limits less than zero or greater than
width just return nil and so you can do
a check on nil to check to see whether
tile map point to tile is equal to nil
or not when you do the collision and if
it is then just you know don't do
anything probably but the on line 32
assuming that you're within the tile
boundaries on line 32 is where you do
that transformation the math dot floor
recall because we want to get integer
values for these we don't want to get
fractional numbers because you can index
the these tiles at fractional numbers
although I'm not sure I'd I think you
might be able to in Lua generally index
a tile via a fractional number but in
this case we just want integers so we
call math dot floor on Y divided by tile
size plus 1y divided up at all size then
add one to that and then we do the same
thing for the X so that's the that's the
operation and then wherever we want to
check for whatever tiles want to collide
for we just call point two tile on those
x and y coordinates and that's the beste
backbone behind all the tile based
collision in the game effectively any
questions as to how this works
yes correct
yeah because you don't you don't really
need to check for the edge if you're
taking into consideration the top and
bottom corner unless your entity is
sufficiently tall that they need to
check for you no more than three tiles
in this case our entity is not more than
two tiles tall so we only need to check
for his top left top right our top left
bottom left if we're doing a left
collision top right bottom right if
we're doing a right collision and a his
top left top right for top and top
bottom left bottom right for bottom if
you had an entity that was like eight
pick eight tiles tall you need to check
every single tile along that along his
right side which just means you need to
iterate over his entire height divided
by tile size and then just offset the Y
that you're checking for each of those
tiles that makes sense okay cool
all right I alluded to this briefly by
mentioning state the sort of are well I
don't know if I alluded so much to the
fact that we're using entities but in
this distro we're introduced to the
concept of entities and entity can be
almost anything you want it to be in
this game in this distro we're
considering entities to basically be
anything that's living or sentient
moving around in this case the player or
snails those are entities and then they
just are subsets of entity and entity is
a very abstract thing you'll see it in a
lot of game engines and a lot of sort of
discussions about how to organize your
game and how to engineer it unity is
probably the most prominent sort of
adopter of what's called the entity
component system whereby you have
everything in your game every single
thing in your game is an entity and then
every entity is comprised of components
and these components ultimately drive
your behavior it's sort of like if
you're familiar with inhae composition
over inheritance if you've heard of this
as like a software engineering thing
that's effectively the same paradigm
like rather than inherit a bunch of
different things to be to be you know
you're like let's say you have a base
monster class and you have like a goblin
that's a
subset of monster so it inherits from
monster and then you have like a goblin
warlord who inherits from goblin then
you have like a ancient goblin warlord
that inherits from that rather than have
like this nested tree of like
inheritance you have you adopt
composition which means you take a base
come like container and then you fill it
with different components that represent
what the behavior of your object is so
if you have a monster or if you have an
entity let's say you give it a monster
component and then maybe your monster
come a B you also give it like an
ancient component so it's an ancient
monster maybe give it a goblin component
so then it's an ancient goblin war or
ancient monster goblin and then you give
it like a warlord component so it's an
ancient goblin monster war light so it
has all the pieces that make it what it
is without you having to create a this
crazy chain of inheritance that's the
effect that's effectively the what the
model of an entity component system is
versus standard inheritance like using
that to drive the model of your problem
in this case we're not going into crazy
entity components but I wanted to bring
it up because in a unity which we will
be covering in a few weeks is entirely a
component based everything you write in
unity is a component and entities
whether they're in an entity component
system or not form the backbone of most
large games like most games that have
some complexity to them model most of
the pieces within them as entities that
have behaviors and do things and so in
this case entities are our snails and
our player and then we separate from the
tiles when we do collision for that we
want to also check collision on every
entity with the player so we make sure
that the player is collided with a snail
or in this case because there's the only
other entities that they can be but you
can have you know an arbitrary number of
enemies if you want to if you collide
with a an entity so just a for loop so
for entity in pairs of entities check
collision if you know you're in the jump
state then
die if you're in the fall state kill it
etc that's generally when you're doing
most of your like entity to entity
interactions stuff like that's generally
how you'll model it you'll just iterate
over everything and then just like
collide everything depending on what
collides with what you'll just collide
everything with everything else and like
process interactions that way that's
effectively how we do it
we have in the I believe it's in game
level this maintains a reference to just
a table full of entities a table full of
objects objects can be we'll talk about
that a second but like gems and blocks
and bushes and stuff like that and then
a tile map and then we just for every
entity we just update it and then every
object we update it and for every object
in objects we render it as well and then
we render every entity like this is just
a sort of like basic how you would take
a game world populate it and then
process and update it just containers
tables that just maintain a bunch of
references to everything and then just
update them the actual interaction takes
place in the because they're dependent
on what state were in if you look at all
of the different states in the player
class or sorry all the different states
for the player in the States
entity folder you'll see for example on
line 62 of the player falling state like
well iterating over every object in like
the level objects and we're notice where
I have a reference to like the player
has a reference to its level so that it
can like access everything within it and
then within that level all the objects
are stored so all they needs to do is
just say if the object collides with the
player and the object is solid then you
know you set our dy to 0 etcetera etc
all this codes actually pretty easy to
read through so I would encourage you to
take a look at it and you sort of
understand how all the collision and
stuff is working for you know between
the player the objects the blocks and
things like that things like blocks are
solid things like bushes are not solid
but that's that's the gist like take
your like have a collection of objects
or entities and then depending on what
state you're in
like collide with some and then what
depending on the state like maybe that
kills you maybe that kills the enemy
maybe nothing happens maybe you become
invincible maybe you like collide with a
powerup game object and that powerup
triggers like your self dot player dot
invincible is true and then if self dot
player dot invincible is true then maybe
you render him with a go Rambo animation
and then in any of the functions where
he would collide and die with an enemy
he no longer dies he just kills them so
that's just sort of like the gist behind
how you would interact with objects in a
kind of process if game objects are
different like I said earlier this is
these are example of like some of the
objects here we can see the gems on the
bottom left there are all in the distro
like if you hit a block and if we have a
few minutes I'll show you really quickly
how that works
if you hit a block you'll or you'll have
a chance to spawn a gem if you collect
the gem which means if you collide with
that game object increment your score by
ten or a hundred these are all other
objects that I didn't have any time to
implement but just off the gate how just
as a mental exercise how how do you
think we could implement like a ladder
yeah
correct so what tani said was if they go
onto a ladder they should go into a
climb state and depending on whether
they're in the climb state or not if
they press a button they should go up or
down yeah you would and then you would
check you know if they're at the top of
the ladder you know get off the climb
state like going to a walk state right
or if they're at the bottom of the
ladder going to a walk state and that's
just you know another game object that
you just collide with them then you're
just you know it's a new state for you
yes Tony said was you could have a you
the ability to jump off a ladder that we
said yeah yeah the ability to jump off a
ladder so that you can then use it as an
obstacle that's absolutely true actually
in the in the mock up that we saw up
here it's super hard to see I'll see if
I can maybe zoom in on it here and Mario
Mario graphics and then it's called full
sheet the whole entire sheet that I used
for this lecture is called full sheet of
PNG I don't know what that is so if we
zoom in really high here we can see
effectively yeah what you were alluding
to like right here this little rope
thing I'm guessing that's the end I'm
guessing for the sake of this mock-up
that sort of what you're trying to
illustrate but you have a you know a
game object that lets you go into a
climb state whether it's a ladder or
whether it's a rope yeah just you know
add a new state for the player if
they're in the if they're in that climb
state then we have you know this new
animation which we saw on the sheet
earlier which is their back or their
front and then they just climb up it you
know I'm just updated if they're moving
up or down the the
the ladder and then just give them the
ability to jump off and then we get the
top or bottom just get off so a lot of
there and you could think of the sort of
a lot of the same thing with a lot of
these obstacles like the spikes here if
you're jumping and you hit it you should
probably die and so you know you would
check for if the object up ID maybe is
equal to spikes or whether object dot is
lethal equals true same thing with this
one and in some obstacles are completely
cosmetic like this mushroom here is just
in the in the case of the distro bushes
and mushrooms and cacti and all those
sorts of things are just completely
cosmetics you can walk through them they
don't trigger collision but they're
rendered as game objects they're not
part of the tile grid so they don't get
applied they don't get rendered with the
or they don't get processed in the same
way as tiles they're not stored in the
YX but yeah so that's effectively sort
of how we can start thinking about
objects and how to give them behavior
part of the assignment is going to be
adding a flag so this flags in the
sprite sheet so what you'll do and I'll
touch on this at the end of the lecture
here we're getting close to it but these
keys here actually at the bottom right
so part of the assignment will be to
it's actually right here so I'll go over
it really quickly so ensure the player
always starts above solid land so in
this case if we when we ran the James
came up here and ran you ran the first
example the very first time that we
spawned the game it generated a chasm
right at the flow right where the player
spawned at sort of x1 and so it just
falls to his death if that happens so
just make sure that you know how and
probably just right off the gate anybody
having ideas as to what we could do to
check to see if we're at solid land
assuming that we start at like the
players default start is at x1
yeah but we probably want to do is like
look all the way down the column right
because we could we start at the back
towards the top but you know if we're
and if we're at if we find that there's
no no tiles down there's just pure chasm
probably want to shift the player and
then random keys and locks so this will
be let me open up level maker so we can
see sort of what you'll be interacting
with because most of what you'll be
doing actually is in level maker level
maker is what it does is it does a lot
of what we did before with just math dot
random and then it will insert into
objects so objects is a table here it
will insert a game object depending on
some logic so in this case if we're
generating a pillar and we have a chance
to generate a bush on the pillar so if
math dot random eight is one in this
case we're already generating a pillar
so we have an additional chance that's
on top of the chest degenerated pillar
so basically a one in I think it's a one
in 64 chance on that particular
iteration to generate a table with a
pillar with a bush you just add a new
game object to objects in this case this
is the sort of the constructor for a
game object you give it an X Y width
height and then a frame and then the
frame is relative to whatever quad table
matches the texture string here so
bushes is the texture and so whatever
quad in bushes you want to give it in
this case we just gave it a random a
random frame from that and then a lot of
the same logic applies to other parts
this is another part where we generate
bushes just on flatland we have a chance
to generate a block one in ten chance
this is a jump block so here we have
texture XY width height frame notice
that we have collidable is true and this
is how we can sort of test to see
whether a tile is collidable or not hit
is false meaning that we haven't hit it
yet and if we have hit it
then we want to
we we do this code basically on collide
gets called and you can read this if you
look and you can see where this gets
called in the collision code for if we
look in player players player has check
left collisions check right collisions
and check object collisions and it
doesn't have checked up-and-down
collisions there was a corner there is a
corner case for both of those such that
the logic had to be duplicated for it
exactly why but you basically get a list
of objects that you check for and then
oh the reason why is because when you
get the collided objects when you're in
the jump State you trigger the on
collide function so let's go to play or
jump State if we're in the jump State
and this is where we basically check to
see if we've gotten any objects that
collide with the player if it's solid
call it on collide function object on
collide and then we just pass in the
object itself basically and so if we go
back to level maker that's where we
write the on collide function we write
the on collide function within the game
object here so we just give it a non
collide remember cuz functions are first
class citizens we can just say on
collide gets function obj where obj is
gonna be this object if it's not if it
wasn't hit already one in five chance to
spawn a gem so going to create a gem
it's got all the same sort of stuff and
in this case it has its own function
called on consumed on consume takes a
player and an object and then this is
all arbitrary by the way you can create
whatever functions you want these are
callback functions effectively we're
gonna play the pickup sound and then add
a 100 to our score and then here in the
event that we did get a gem
we tween it over the course of point 1
seconds between its y2b we from like
below the block 2 up above so it has
like an upwards animation effectively
and then we have another sound up place
but that's effectively how we're
spawning game objects game objects have
textures XY with height and then you can
give them callback functions that you
then execute wherever it's relevant to
you in this case you'll only really need
to worry about on collide because the
assignment is create random keys and
locks can be they have to be the same
color but you can choose which use them
at random if the player collides with
the key then he should probably get some
flag that's like key obtained is true or
something like that and then you go go
to the the block that spawns in the
level so you should spawn a block with
that same color and then on collide you
should unlock it so get rid of the block
and then spawn a new game object the
flag and then that flag
he'll have its own on collide and when
you collide with the flag restart the
level and that's effectively the gist
behind the problem set so probably
shouldn't take I would say probably
maybe 40 or 50 lines of code probably
should do it yeah
it is a class so here's yeah there's a
game object class a game object is
basically and I realize I didn't touch
on it too much it's basically in the
context of this distro you could almost
think of it as an entity in this case
what I've done is I've differentiated
between living things and nonliving
things as being entities versus game
objects which is a semi arbitrary
distinction but for a small project like
this it sort of makes sense for a large
project I would maybe probably create
everything as an entity and then give
different kinds of entities their own
behavior and their own components sort
of like you do with an entity component
system there is actually instant so
while you're talking to the question was
are there is there more than one way to
create a class in Lua whether it's
parentheses or curly brackets and yes I
don't think I ever actually talked about
this but Lua allows you if you generate
air let's go back to level maker if you
instantiate a class and that class just
takes in a table just a table as its
only argument you can just pass in this
whoops sorry this effectively is that
argument table you don't need
parentheses you can just it's
effectively doing this same thing only
you don't need the parentheses
correct it's just a it's just an
alternative form of instantiation on
things that only take a table as their
as their argument for when they get
instantiate it correct yes yeah
can you say it one more time the
question was if you wanted to wouldn't
it be easier to generate a helper to
create a helper class that would allow
you to instantiate gems possibly the I
mean I think if I if you were going to
design this a little bit more robustly
and if this were going to be a larger
game then you would just create a
subclass for blocks
gems etc to shrink the number of files
that we had in the distro and to sort of
consolidate everything together and put
all of the sort of level code together
in one spot I decided to just create
game object as sort of like an abstract
class that you could then just create
your own behavior for within the actual
constructor which is this bit here which
is just the table and then I allow you
to override the on collide and on
consume functions and you can actually
give it whatever functions you want you
could you could give this some arbitrary
named function and then test for it
later this is sort of almost like an
obscure way of inheritance but the I
think if I were to engineer this and
they with the goal of making it a really
large game I would just subclass all of
the I would just create a class for Jam
a class for block a class for Bush etc
etc it wasn't strictly necessary for
this example so we ended up keeping
everything a little bit more sort of
abstract I guess in the sense a little
bit more general purpose but yeah you
could you could definitely you can
definitely create classes for those and
if you were an entity component system
you could have like a consumable
component and then that consumable
component would then allow you to
give it some sort of behavior that
affects the player when the player
consumes that object in this case that
gem is a consumable so you would just
give it a consumable component with the
texture of the gem and then give that
function give it a callback function
that just increments the player score
and probably probably put that in like
ten or fifteen lines of code be pretty
easy and then blocks would be like a
like a a spawner component so they have
a chance to spawn and then you would
pass in that spawner component like a
gem maybe and then so it would spawn
that I have a chance to spawn the gym
they pass into the spawner component and
then also like a collidable come like a
a solid component to say oh this is
solid so if I hit it I should like
trigger a collision and not be able to
walk through it so you just sort of
layer on these components I would
encourage you to sort of think about
this way of composing your objects a
little bit particularly as we get
towards unity which makes really sort of
a lot of use of this concept but yeah in
short yes I think that's pretty much
everything let's let me just go ahead
we're running out of time here but like
I said one more time
if the make sure player starts above
solid land random color key and lock and
then make sure that when you get the key
you can unlock the lock and that spawns
the goal so this will all this is all
something you can just add to your level
maker at the level maker class and
that'll just sort of it'll all sort of
work with your game level that way and
then when you finish the goal flag then
respawn the level so next time today we
talked about Super Mario Brothers the
other big nintendo game of that era
arguably one of the greatest of all time
is zelda so we'll be talking about a
very simple sort of Legend of Zelda game
where we just have like a random dungeon
that we can go through a top-down
perspective fight simple monsters open
chests blow up walls that sort of thing
we'll talk about triggers and events and
then we'll talk about hurt boxes
inventory a very simple GUI for like
opening up a menu and then world states
so that we can see you know which doors
have been blasted open so that they
render appropriately and whatnot
and that's that's it for Mario so thanks
a lot for coming I'll see you guys next
time